a coin that is the that is the forked
Bitcoin created by a con we have wait
what that's exists yeah you heard about
that a coin
what a ko iin a coin yeah bro I have
some [ __ ] we got to talk about one coin
did we ever talk about that no the point
is that the coin that that works off of
every single other coin no okay no right
no that sounds dope though that sounds
dope you talking about like one coin has
like a parent and they a slit alittle
kids yeah yeah coin babies yeah a little
coin baby
okay little coin e babies and that
produces more coin babies since you just
have infinite right right the coins
doing coitus that sounds dope a nice
coin this coin this you see that's we'll
talk about that after but no no let's no
[ __ ] that
let's start coin this okay and it's it
is a it is a crypto oriented strictly
towards swinging and wild orgies it's
it's strictly for that okay that's it
how does it work well it's it's imbedded
in devices and you know we the coin dis
technology is preloaded so when you go
to like a like a big sex club all the
devices they accept coin this so if you
guys if you swipe your chip or your
phone it'll auto charge the coin de s--
and world's our oyster you don't have to
think when you're in the sex club you
use anything in there swipe your chip I
think Auto decade you point us account
vibrators on okay bride right into the
sex okay sex swing unlocked yeah
just [ __ ] falls down from the ceiling
piss chamber opens right away like
shower so wipe your coin dis and a hatch
opens from the roof and just yeah
drenched in piss
yeah oh you know you know you know guy
approaches you in the club a min
you seem like a cool guy I was wondering
if you want to pee on my girlfriend and
yeah I'd love to - then he taps his
pockets he goes oh I left my said don't
worry about it I got a coin disbalance
he's like oh thank god
thank God I left my coin dis wallet at
home you know it goes and they have a
nice good anyway that sounds cool man
that sounds cool it sounds even better
than a coin you be honest you didn't
know about a coin no I had no idea
that's so funny
yeah it's a coin yeah ako I am that I
owe a new cryptocurrency digital wallet
with an integrated ecosystem of deep
DAPs
d apps decentralized crypto apps that
will provide immediate and ongoing new
revenue some some some so I think you're
supposed to be an african cryptocurrency
yeah bro I hate how crypto sites are
just they all look all this language
just looks like homework or something
that's in a textbook this doesn't feel
real at all yeah yeah it's so true q4
2020 a Khan city integration oh I forgot
he's building a city right damn that's
coming up
q4 should we check in with a coins
brother this was November 20th right
here's six billion dollar cryptocurrency
city set to begin construction holy [ __ ]
dude what a con he's really doing it bro
he's building a literal Empire holy [ __ ]
man it's you know who got in trouble for
that like years ago was like the
Rockefellers who hold on big big for oil
uh so he's building so he built this
cryptocurrency yeah he's gonna have the
people fund it and then they're all
gonna move to this city where that's the
only currency and he's just gonna be
like like Emperor I guess so um
I'm trying to remember which there was
like one of these so there's like the
rockefellers and then some other big
family that that owned oil and they
created their own currency on the
[ __ ] site of like the oil company and
they had housing and [ __ ] it was a
similar thing and people there didn't
make real money and then they actually
got in trouble Jesus although when was
this little good 1900s or some [ __ ]
oh man someone who does the homework and
and all that someone needs to verify
that for me but a con is doing the same
[ __ ] that is crazy
what's gonna be in his City yeah what
would a can't have in his City I mean
dude definitely no other you know the
music playlist for all the retail stores
is gonna be super limited it's just
gonna be him it's just his catalog it's
just gonna be his upcoming song six nine
yeah oh man that whole clip was so sad
to me oh of them sitting there singing
with him yeah bro people people given so
much like a con I can't [ __ ] believe
it's like dude do you think he cares
he's building a city yeah yeah he's
worried about way bigger [ __ ] going on
right now he does not care about your
opinion holy [ __ ] man
you